всего одна привычка которая изменит вашу
жизнь на до и после если бы меня
спросили какую привычку вы бы оставили
себе если бы мне сказали бы у вас нет
других вариантов то я бы оставил именно
её все люди хотят получить волшебную
палочку или золотую рыбку на худой конец
Все хотят найти какой-то Секрет или
какой-то лайфхак к тому же вокруг в
социальных сетях везде очень много
различных знаний лайфхаков способов
техники и так далее и так далее но в
этом огромном изобилии нам нужно чётко
понимать что реально хорошо действует А
что работает не всегда я с вами поделюсь
своим опытом за свои 30 лет занятия
бизнесами и инвестициями в которых я
достигал огромных высот у меня было
более сотен компаний Я заработал 6 почти
6 млрд долларов То есть я перепробовал
всё
все прелести жизни миллиардера и в то же
время я прошёл весь этот путь и что я в
себе заметил И чего мне раньше не
хватало мне не хватало именно этой
привычки К сожалению эту привычку я
приобрёл позже но последние почти 15 лет
я Благодаря этой привычке достигаю
основных своих успехов Так в чём
заключается эта привычка я называю эту
привычку ча почему кайзен и почему час
Дело в том что кайзен - это японская
философия непрерывного совершенствования
То
есть это философия при котором люди
процессы бизнеса всё время должны
совершенствоваться А почему час потому
что именно этот час я посвящаю этому
делу Каждое утро я просыпаюсь и после
занятия ходьбой Я сажусь за Кан час те
улучшения в сво жизни которые я получаю
они происходят не благодаря тем
действиям которые я делаю в течение дня
а больше благодаря тому что я Какие
решения принимаю в течение этого кайзен
часа решения принятые в течение этого
кайзен часа имеют мультипликативный
мультиплит Я бы ещё называю
это эффект сложных процентов когда
эффект с годами только накапливается
почему это происходит потому что во
время этого часа Я задаю себе вопросы
что мне нужно улучшить что мне нужно
сделать Что мне нужно сделать так чтобы
делать что-то эффективнее что мне нужно
сделать что-то чтобы делать это с
меньшими затратами с меньшей энергии
тратить на это меньше времени что мне
нужно автоматизировать что мне нужно
делегировать А что мне там нужно
подправить что новое Изучить и так далее
То есть этот час в течение которого Я
размышляю только об эффективности своей
деятельности которой я буду заниматься в
остальное время и почему даёт этот кайн
час даёт такой мультипликативный эффект
потому что в это время я пишу свои
алгоритмы Я пишу свои стандарты Почему
Важно писать алгоритмы Давайте Я приведу
пример вот Представьте вы лезете на
дерево Да вы лезете на дерево лезете
лезете 15 лет уже своей жизни 20 лет
своей жизни а потом выбрали не ту ветку
и баба упали на землю ВС большинство
людей считает всё жизнь кончилась потому
что новых 152 лет у них нет энергии уже
не та и они не делают второй попытки Но
когда у вас есть алгоритм прописанный
как лезть на это дерево и не ошибаться
не уходить в Тупиковый ветви вы
понимаете что теперь повтор этого пути
займёт у вас гораздо меньше времени Ну
года два и таким образом вы через 2 года
будете опять в той же точке с которой
сорвались я шучу и часто называю
успешного человека это тот человек
который ежедневно поедает события а
сзади выпускает ресурсы То есть если вы
не научились конвертировать события
которые с вами происходят в ресурсы то
вы неэффективны А в чём могут выражаться
ресурсы Например я познакомился с одним
человеком и прол встречу как попало не
зарядил его идёт Я просто потратил час
времени и всё А если я с этим человеком
поговорил от души с душой а говорил о
конкретных проектах Не о политике там не
о тех вещах которые вне моего контроля а
о конкретных конкретном проекте
конкретных действиях и так далее либо
замотивировать его то что в этот момент
произошло я приобрёл связи я приобрёл
связи потому что А у меня появился
человек который теперь будет думать о
том как бы что-то сделать с маргуланом
либо я что-то делаю и совершил ошибку
это событие со мной произошло как это
превратить в ресурс я прописываю
алгоритм Что нужно делать или что не
нужно делать чтобы эта ошибка не
повторилась алгоритм является ресурсом
Почему алгоритм является ресурсом потому
что
алгоритм экономит мне время в будущем
мне не надо будет тратить свои ресурсы
на совершение
в этой жизни не надо бояться совершать
ошибок но надо бояться совершать два
типа ошибок первый тип - это ошибки с
необратимыми последствиями и второй тип
ошибок - это ошибки которые постоянно
повторяются все эти моменты можно
избежать Если у вас есть кайзен час в
течение которого вы
оттачивает на другом примере Если вы
Дровосек то 247 рубить лес это не самый
эффективный путь А если Вы каждый день
будете затрачивать по одному часу на
затачивание топора то ваша эффективность
вырастет гораздо больше
Поэтому вот этот кайн час
является эффектом рычага этот час
увеличивает эффективность всех остальных
моих рабочих часов если предположим
человек работает 8 часов то потратьте
час на повышение своей эффективности и
ваши 7 часов Бут давать отдачу как 14
как 20 как 30 Кан час - это основной
рычаг Поэтому применяйте в своей жизни
это несложно Выделите каждое утро оди
час или хотя бы полчаса когда вы будете
думать только о том как оптимизировать
свою деятельность и это Поверьте мне
принесёт вам большие плоды и Вы не
узнаете свою жизнь она поделится на до и
после можете помочь Тем людям которым
им даже сложно в календарик задачи
записывать для них это пытка как им
начать вообще планировать свою жизнь и
целый час выделить Может какой-то есть
секрет какм это проще в свою жизнь
привнести для тех кто хочет внедрить
свою жизнь Кача Не начинайте с часа
начните с 10 минут просто начните с 10
минут в которых первое проы
де Где вы теряли больше всего энергию
Посмотрите Где вы больше всего получали
какое-то неудовольствие и подумайте Что
нужно сделать в будущем Что нужно
сделать чтобы этого не повторилось вот и
всё Это и будет частью кайзен часа это
же на самом деле всё просто вот э в нас
генетически встроен механизм э
постоянной оптимизации если мы идём по
одной тропе и постоянно спотыкается на
какой-то лестнице то мы в следующий раз
предпочитаем обойти эту лестницу Ну это
же встроено то же самое просто вам нужно
что сделать прежде всего вспомнить
вчерашний день и Вспомнить всё то что
вас не устроило во вчерашнем дне это
может быть какие-то события или встречи
которые у вас забрали энергию и
испортили вам настроения либо это могут
быть какие-то события или действия
которые вызвали вас в в вас раздражение
или не позволили вам добиться своего ну
и соответственно подумайте о том что
нужно сделать чтобы в будущем этого не
было всё Напишите каждый раз когда я в
следующий раз буду сталкиваться с этим я
буду делать Вот так и это облегчит вашу
жизнь Я всю жизнь занимаюсь написанием
алгоритмов для себя и благодаря этим
алгоритмам моя жизнь становится гораздо
гораздо проще и это не вопрос того чтобы
там уметь планировать или чего-то это
даже не про планы алгоритм это не планы
планирование у меня отдельно есть у меня
есть час планирования потом есть кайн
час на в часе планирования я произвожу
аудит каждый день переоценку своих целей
там другие задачи я выполняю А вот на
Кай час я пишу алгоритмы и думаю о том
как оптимизировать свою жизнь Как
повысить её эффективность почему потому
что один раз записанный алгоритм
работает на бесконечное количество
случаев Ну условно У меня есть алгоритм
когда у меня просит деньги проблема лю в
том что они не могут сказать Нет они не
могут отказать И думают что это черта
характера на самом деле это не черта
характера это ваша неподготовленность
Когда у вас просят деньги у вас нечем
крыть Вы вынуждены дать а когда у вас
есть алгоритм Как отвечать Как отвечать
так чтобы человек не обиделся то Вы
спокойно говорите Нет я научил многих
своих учеников этим техникам тому нет А
тому как правильно выстраивать алгоритмы
и свою жизнь и ещё короткий вопрос про
инструменты эти алгоритмы они записаны
где как это блокнот Это заметки в
ноутбуке в телефоне стикеры как это
выглядит вот физически все свои
алгоритмы Я записываю в своей записной
книжке это даже не записная книжка Это у
меня проект называется второй мозг я
записываю в приложении obsidan это очень
сложное приложение Я же вам рекомендую
просто записывать в записной книжке в
каждом Айфоне или Android смартфоне есть
записная книжка Откройте там папку
Назовите алгоритмы звучит сложно
алгоритм Но на самом деле суть то проста
это вспомнить те свои ошибки или то что
доставило вам беспокойство и написать то
что Вы должны сделать чтобы в следующий
раз это не повторилось и привязать это к
какому-то правильному названию например
как правильно отказывать Когда у вас
просить деньги Ну в любые алгоритмы
лучше начинать со слов как как правильно
отказывать или как добиваться своего Как
вести переговоры как учитывать мнение
других У меня есть алгоритмы даже как
выражать благодарность и эти алгоритмы
намного облегчают жизнь человека ещё
одно чем я занимаюсь во время кайн часа
- это формирование своих привычек
формирование привычек это очень важная
часть и именно во время кайзен часа я
определяю Какие привычки Я хочу внедрить
в свою жизнь философии говорится что
самые большие изменения в нашу жизнь
привносят ежедневные маленькие привычки
учёные по-моему гарвардского
университета они посчитали что человек в
течение дня принимает больше 10.000
решений и большая часть этих решений
принимается автоматически то есть на
основе привычек около 92% 90-95
различные цифр прит 90-92 5% всех
решений мы принимаем на основе привычек
так вот если представить что ваша жизнь
равна 100 годам то 90-95 лет Вы живёте
на основе привычек Поэтому после кайзен
часа следующий сильнейший рычаг который
меняет вашу жизнь - это привычки поэтому
во время кайзен часта определяйте какие
привычки вы хотите внедрить в свою жизнь
с вами останутся не те действия и те
дела которыми вы заняты Сегодня с вами
останутся ваши привычки поэтому
внимательно относитесь к и именно к этим
маленьким вроде бы незаметным вещам
которые принесут наибольшие изменения в
вашу жизнь если вам интересно следить и
смотреть за тем как я внедряют жизнь и
вообще какие алгоритмы я вношу я этим
делюсь в своём Telegram канале
переходите по ссылке внизу и там
встретимся